yeah see they kicked him off YouTube
right so he's only on Rumble yeah he
can't post at all I think Schultz was
talking about he's like yeah and then I
got a YouTube the lady works at
YouTube's number I harass her and talk
[__] to her he was like yeah and then I
found out one of the heads at YouTube I
got her cell phone every so time time
I'll get a little drunk and just spit
off a hard attack yeah he's like yo like
well she's like no never dude you're
never gonna I want him to come back so
bad it's just it's a weird thing because
like he doesn't need to yeah and even if
you don't say like Steve's in the video
if they if just his image shows up voice
his face everything damn he's completely
[__] off YouTube like if he did some
real [__] up [__] then like everyone
would be like yo we're not really
filming with you so it's a weird cause
I'll go please a good dude great dude
great person super Heart of Gold so it's
like thank God he doesn't have to worry
about it because he was Rumble he does
his thing crushes it